Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Bonjour à toutes et à tous.
Comme l’a dit Rémy, je m’appelle
Ivo Da Silva, j’ai 31 ans.
Je suis étudiant en journalisme
à l’IHECS, qui est une école bruxelloise,
Dans le cadre d’un mémoire médiatique,
mon équipe et moi-même nous sommes
intéressés à la prison du futur.
L’idée, c’est un nouveau
système carcéral en Belgique
qui va peut-être révolutionner
le milieu de la prison.
On a choisi ce thème -
c’est vraiment parti
d’un constat assez simple -
car on a remarqué que la prison classique,
comme on la connaît depuis très longtemps,
elle ne fonctionne pas,
ou elle fonctionne mal.
Parfois même, elle crée
de nouveaux problèmes.
Mais avant de vous parler
des maisons de détention,
je vais vous demander juste
de prendre un instant pour réfléchir,
un instant pour vous demander
si vous accepteriez ou non
que la prison du futur
se trouve à côté de chez vous
et que les détenus puissent sortir
occasionnellement en journée
pour travailler, pour suivre une formation
ou suivre une thérapie.
Prenez bien le temps d’y réfléchir
et soyez bien sûr honnête avec vous-même.
Est-ce que vous trouvez l’idée farfelue,
voire dangereuse ?
Pensez-vous que
les personnes qui sont incarcérées
et qui ont donc commis des fautes doivent
l’être 7 jours sur 7 et 24 h sur 24 ?
Ou au contraire, accepteriez-vous
de leur laisser davantage de liberté
à condition peut-être que ces personnes
ne se trouvent pas à côté de chez vous ?
Je vous rassure tout de suite,
il n’y a évidemment pas de bonne
ou de mauvaise réponse à ces questions.
Toutes vos réponses sont légitimes.
Ce sont des questions
importantes, délicates, qui font écho
à de grands principes qui structurent
nos sociétés depuis pas mal de temps :
la liberté, la sécurité, la dignité
humaine et bien sûr l’espoir.
Si la Belgique a décidé aujourd’hui de
parier sur une nouvelle façon d’incarcérer
et de traiter les détenus,
c’est sans aucun doute car le système
carcéral actuel n’est pas assez efficace.
Prenons l’exemple de la France.
La surpopulation carcérale est chronique :
il n’y a pas assez de places
de prison opérationnelles
par rapport au nombre de détenus,
et ce depuis très longtemps.
Fin 2021, le taux d’occupation
dans les prisons françaises
était de 115,4%, ce qui est
évidemment beaucoup trop.
Dans certaines prisons françaises,
comme les maisons d’arrêt à Nîmes,
ou encore ici, juste à côté de Bordeaux,
à Gradignan, il me semble,
ce taux d’occupation,
il dépasse les 200%.
C’est juste énorme, on sera d’accord.
Moi qui viens de Belgique,
chez moi, c’est pareil.
C’est-à-dire que le taux d’occupation
moyen dans les prisons est de 120,6 %.
Toujours trop.
Mais ce sont des chiffres, c’est hyper
théorique, je vous donne des chiffres.
Mais concrètement, qu’est-ce que
ça donne dans la vie des gens ?
Concrètement, ça donne
des gardiens à bout,
très en colère.
Concrètement, ça donne des détenus qui
dorment parfois sur des matelas au sol,
à quatre ou cinq dans
des cellules de deux.
Ça provoque donc la colère des gardiens,
mais aussi des familles des prisonniers,
des psychologues de prison.
Parfois, les prisons sont même vétustes.
Et on parle bien de la France
et de la Belgique.
Je ne sais pas si on se rend bien compte
que la Cour européenne
des droits de l’Homme
a condamné la Belgique et la France pour
mauvaise gestion, mauvais traitement
de leurs prisonniers.
Honnêtement -
ce n’est que mon point de vue -
je trouve ça gênant pour des pays
comme la France et la Belgique,
qui sont censés être leaders en matière
de respect de la dignité humaine.
Raison pour laquelle donc la Belgique
a créé de nouvelles maisons de détention.
Je vous en parle dans le détail
dans quelques secondes.
Ce que je veux dire aussi,
c’est que, outre les problèmes
dans le quotidien des prisonniers -
c’est du court terme, c’est du présent -
il faut voir à l’avenir ce que
ces conditions de détention provoquent.
Eh bien, la récidive, la récidive
et encore la récidive.
En France, près d’un ex-détenu sur trois -
près de 30 % des détenus -
récidive dans l’année de sortie de prison.
En Belgique, ce n’est pas beaucoup mieux,
c’est même pire : dans 57% des cas,
l’auteur, l’ex-détenu,
récidive une nouvelle fois.
C'est juste énorme.
Et évidemment, ces maisons de détention
sont donc porteuses d’espoir !
Les maisons de détention,
elles n’accueilleront qu’entre 20 et
60 détenus, ce qui est vraiment peu.
Pendant la journée,
les détenus pourront donc sortir,
afin de suivre des formations,
suivre des thérapies,
voir leur famille et même travailler.
L’objectif est simple : c’est
de ne pas trop les couper de la société,
de leur laisser une certaine
liberté de mouvement
et un certain droit aux contacts sociaux.
L’emplacement des maisons de détention
aussi est très important
puisqu’en fait, l’idée, si les premières
maisons de détention fonctionnent,
c’est d’en avoir
un peu partout en Belgique
et, pourquoi pas un jour,
sur le territoire français
pour que les détenus
soient proches de leur famille
afin de toujours garder ce contact social.
En revanche,
ce ne seront pas tous les détenus.
Toutes les personnes condamnées
n’iront pas dans ces maisons de détention,
mais uniquement les personnes
qui ont une peine de moins
de trois ans d’emprisonnement.
Il n’y aura donc pas de violeurs,
de terroristes
ou de délinquants trop violents.
Théoriquement, on est d’accord,
ça a l’air génial, vraiment.
Théoriquement,
c’est un pas dans la bonne direction.
Mais ça, c’est théorique.
Parce que, bien sûr, cela soulève
des questions, pas mal de questions,
et en particulier
une contradiction majeure.
Les gens qui vont être enfermés
dans ces maisons de détention,
jusqu’ici, ils n’étaient pas enfermés.
Ils bénéficiaient de sursis
ou d’un bracelet électronique.
Ce qui veut donc dire que, là,
désormais, elles seront incarcérées.
Je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure
de la surpopulation carcérale.
On peut bien sûr se demander si ouvrir
de nouvelles maisons de détention
est une bonne idée
quand on voit déjà la détresse
et le nombre de personnes
qui sont incarcérées.
Mais les maisons de détention,
il ne faut pas les -
Il faut essayer de prendre du recul,
de prendre de la hauteur,
de regarder à long terme.
Je vous l’ai dit tout à l’heure,
on veut lutter contre la récidive.
C’est donc pour ça que les maisons
de détention vont naître en Belgique.
Elles seront plus contraignantes
que le bracelet électronique
ou bien évidemment que le sursis,
mais moins contraignantes que les prisons.
C’est donc sur cet équilibre,
sur ce compromis
que souhaite parier l'État belge.
Une question n’a eu de cesse de traverser
la philosophie depuis des siècles :
comment donner du sens à la peine ?
Comment punir un délit à sa juste mesure ?
Comment punir un crime à sa juste mesure ?
Et où placer le curseur entre, d’une part,
sévérité et intransigeance,
et d’autre part, empathie
et dignité humaine, bien sûr ?
C’est le grand défi de la justice -
je n’ai évidemment pas les réponses.
Mais ce qui est très frappant,
c’est que depuis Platon à aujourd’hui,
le sens qu’on a donné à la peine
a toujours été celui la prison,
de l’enfermement.
Socrate, par exemple,
questionnait déjà le fait d’être puni
sans pour autant être contre la prison.
Tandis qu’Aristote, lui,
s’interrogeait sur la juste mesure
qu’il y a entre la faute et la peine.
Un autre penseur, Michel Foucault,
plus contemporain,
a écrit en septante-cinq, ou
soixante-quinze, comme on dit en France,
dans « Surveiller ou punir », une
réflexion très intéressante sur la prison.
Il s’est alors posé
les questions suivantes.
Peut-on punir sans peine ?
Prenez bien le temps d’y réfléchir.
Peut-on punir un délit
ou un crime sans incarcération ?
Et faut-il faire souffrir
celui ou celle qui a fait souffrir -
pour que justice soit rendue,
que la faute soit expiée, corrigée,
voire pardonnée ?
Une nouvelle fois,
je n’ai pas les réponses à ça.
Mais ce que je retiens précisément
de ce qu’a écrit Michel Foucault,
c’est que, selon lui,
l’excès n’est pas nécessaire.
Bien au contraire.
L’objectif, il est celui de la plus
grande économie du système pénal.
C’est là, le sens de l’humanité.
Ce qui est véritablement important, en
effet, dans la nouvelle réalité sociale,
ce n'est pas l'exemplarité de la peine.
Non, c'est son efficacité et c'est donc
le rôle des maisons de détention.
Leur but,
c’est la recherche de l’efficacité,
en laissant donc un certain nombre
de libertés aux détenus.
Je sais que c’est difficile - j’imagine -
pour vous de vous sentir impliqué,
de vous sentir concerné par
la problématique que sont les prisons.
On a chacun une vie, des problèmes,
on a chacun des joies, des peines.
Mais l’objectif est
de sanctionner les délinquants
tout en leur apportant de l’aide,
voire, j’irais même plus loin,
en leur apportant de l’espoir.
L’espoir, c’est précisément
ce qu’il manque à beaucoup de gens,
à toutes ces personnes
qui commettent des crimes, des délits,
qui n’ont peut-être pas eu la même chance
que nous d’avoir des parents aimants,
une éducation solide
ou un environnement social sain.
Nous sommes toutes et tous en constante
évolution, en constante croissance.
Selon le philosophe anglophone Alan Watts,
nous avons parfaitement
le droit de ne pas être
la personne que
nous étions il y a 5 minutes.
Oui, nous avons ce droit-là.
Notre choix est de savoir si l’on préfère
être une meilleure personne
ou une moins bonne personne.
Et c’est précisément l’espoir
qui fait que nous avons envie
d’être meilleur demain qu’hier.
L’inverse ne marche pas trop.
L’espoir, c’est un grand mot.
Mais l'espoir, c'est vraiment le but.
Je vais être honnête avec vous : je ne
sais pas si ces maisons vont fonctionner.
Il va falloir du temps pour tirer un
bilan, des années, des décennies,
pour savoir si elles sont
efficaces ou non.
Mais au moins, nous essayons.
Et c’est ça, la clé.
Nous essayons.
Ça fait des dizaines d’années,
voire des siècles,
que la prison fait souffrir
les gardiens, le personnel,
les prisonniers, la famille,
tout le monde.
Alors, il est temps que ça change.
Si ça ne marche pas
cette fois-ci, tant pis.
Si les maisons de détention
ne sont pas efficaces, tant pis.
Au moins, nous essayons.
Je ne dirai qu’une chose :
ayons de l’espoir.
Ayons de l’espoir pour les prisonniers,
pour leurs familles, pour les gardiens.
Ayons de l’espoir, pour vous, pour moi.
Et pour nous tous.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)